this is your two-minute warning for the
breasts breathing
Oh
but we'll good afternoon everyone I'm
Alex azar Secretary of Health and Human
Services and chairman of the president's
Task Force on the novel corona virus I'm
gonna start by turning things over to
dr. Robert Redfield the director of the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention to discuss the current
situation on the novel coronavirus dr.
Wakefield Thank You mr. secretary
let me give you an update on the current
situation of the novel coronavirus first
though I want to emphasize that this is
a serious health situation in China but
I want to emphasize that the risk to the
American public currently is low
our goal is do all we can do to keep it
that way
second I want to recognize the concern
that the American public may have and I
want to reiterate what I just said
currently the risk to the American
public is low as of today there are
nearly 9700 cases in China with more
than 200 deaths
additionally currently there are another
23 countries that have confirmed totally
132 cases this also includes 12
individuals who have been confirmed in
six countries who did not travel to
China CDC has launched an aggressive
Public Health response
focused on early case recognition
isolation of those cases identified and
contact tracing around those individuals
this response is a layered response
which includes both targeted airport
screening as well as heightened
education and awareness of the American
healthcare community to be vigilant in
ascertaining the possibility of recent
travel to China when they are evaluating
patients with upper respiratory tract
infection today we have confirmed six
cases of this
a virus in the United States most recent
case had no travel history to China but
was a close personal contact of one of
the previous cases that we had
identified through our aggressive
contact tracing in addition they're
currently a hundred and ninety-one
individuals that are under investigation
once again I want to emphasize that this
is a significant global situation and it
continues to evolve but I also want to
emphasize again that the risk at this
time to the American public is low mr.
secretary thank you dr. Redfield I would
now like to invite dr. Anthony Fauci the
director of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Disease to
discuss the underlying rationale for the
actions that I will be discussing after
he concludes thank you very much mr.
secretary the concept that's underlying
the action that you'll hear about
shortly is the issue of the unknown
aspects of this particular outbreak so
let me enumerate just a few of these I
can start off by putting it into
perspective by telling you I often get
asked we have an influenza outbreak here
we have about 8,000 deaths already we
have about a hundred thousand
hospitalizations why are we paying such
attention and why are we doing the kinds
of things we're doing here right now
well the reason is despite the morbidity
and mortality with influenza there's a
certainty for example of seasonal flu I
can tell you all guaranteed that as we
get into March and April the flu cases
are going to go down you could predict
pretty accurately what the range of the
mortality is and the hospitalizations as
we've done over the years the issue now
with this is that there's a lot of
unknowns as you can see just from the
media the number of cases have steeply
inclined each and every day you know
that in the beginning we were not sure
if there were asymptomatic infection
which would make it a much broader
outbreak than what we're seeing now we
know for sure that there
it was not clear whether an asymptomatic
person could transmit it to someone
while they were asymptomatic now we know
from a recent report from Germany that
that is absolutely the case there are a
number of countries outside of China
that have travel related cases and now
what we're seeing is that there are
secondary cases from them and as Bob
mentioned we also have that in this
country the pwho has issued as you know
of a public health emergency of
international concern declaration if you
put all these things together I
underscore what Bob said we still have a
low risk to the American public but we
want to keep it at a low risk and
because there are so many unknowns here
we're gonna take the action that the
secretary will describe in a temporary
way to make sure we mitigate as best as
we possibly can
this risk thank you thank you dr. Falchi
today President Trump took decisive
action to minimize the risk of the
spread of novel coronavirus in the
United States since taking office
President Trump has been clear his top
priority is the safety of the American
people in addition to the steps that the
doctors have outlined we continue to
operationalize a multi-layered
cross-agency
public health response following the
World Health Organization's decision to
declare the 2019 Oval coronavirus a
public health emergency of international
concern I have today declared that the
coronavirus presents a public health
emergency in the United States the
actions we have taken and continued to
take complement complement the work of
China and the World Health Organization
to contain the outbreak within China in
accordance with the declaration
beginning at 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time Sunday February the second the
United States government will implement
temporary measures to increase our
abilities to detect and contain the
Canuck the coronavirus proactively and
aggressively any US citizen returning to
the united states who has been in hebei
province in the previous 14 days will be
subjected to up to 14 days of mandatory
quarantine to ensure they fur bare
provided proper medical care and health
screening to be clear this applies only
to US citizens who have been in Hebei
province in the past 14 days prior to
their attempted entry into the United
States any US citizen returning to the
United States who has been in the rest
of mainland China within the previous 14
days will undergo proactive entry health
screening at a select number of ports of
entry and up to 14 days of monitored
self quarantine to ensure they've not
contracted the virus and do not pose a
public health risk
additionally the president has signed a
presidential proclamation using his
authority pursuant to section 212 F of
the Immigration and Nationality Act
temporarily suspending the entry into
the United States of foreign nationals
who pose a risk of transmitting the 2019
novel corona virus as a result foreign
nationals other than immediate family of
US citizens and permanent residents who
have traveled in China within the last
14 days will be denied entry into the
United States for this time once again
these actions will become effective at
5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time Sunday
February 2nd
these prudent targeted and temporary
actions will decrease the pressure on
public health officials screening
incoming travelers expedite the
processing of US citizens return and
permanent residence
returning from China and ensure
resources are focused on the health and
safety of the American people I want to
stress the risk of infection for
Americans remains low and with these and
our previous actions we are working to
keep the risk low all agencies are
working aggressively to monitor this
continually evolving situation and to
keep the public informed in a constantly
transparent way the United States
appreciates China's efforts and
coordination with public health
officials across the globe and continues
to encourage the highest levels of
transparency it is likely that we will
continue to see more cases in the United
States in the coming days and weeks
including some limited person-to-person
transmission the American public can be
assured the full weight of the US
government is working to safeguard the
health and safety of the American people
I'd now like to invite deputy secretary
of state steve vegan for an update good
afternoon and thank you secretary azar
my name is Steve vegan I'm the deputy
secretary of state and I represent the
State Department on the president's
novel coronavirus task force let me
describe briefly the role of the
Department of State in the Proceedings
of this task force in our contributions
our first responsibility is to monitor
events on the ground in China where we
have the presence of US diplomats and to
give clear inaccurate advice to American
citizens and in particular American
travelers considering visiting or
staying in China in this particular case
this includes identifying any health or
safety risks to which they may be
subjected but also very importantly
identifying their access to essential
services such as health care in parts of
China that are affected by this
coronavirus China has an excellent
health care system but in parts of the
country it is simply overwhelmed in the
accessibility to that health care for
any reason including potential infection
but also any other type of accident in
need of medical
may be compromised during the Chinese
government's own treatment of the
consequences of this virus finally we
also make our judgments based upon any
obstacles particularly obstacles to
movement that American citizens might
face in the country and in China we have
seen barriers to travel both within and
without China as well as as well as
between the United States and China and
so we have given prudent advice over the
course of the week to American citizens
in order for them to allow them to make
the best possible choices for themselves
our second responsibility is to assist
US citizens in the affected areas as
much as possible because we have a
presence on the ground we can provide
advice and in some cases we can make
other arrangements
but I want to emphasize this as as
possible and we will continue to review
what we can do in certain circumstances
finally and very importantly the core
mission of the Department of State is to
work closely with our international
partners and in this case we are working
very closely with the Chinese government
in order to address a number of related
matters well let me start on behalf of
the president in the Secretary of State
by extending our deepest compassion to
the people of China this has been a very
difficult time for the Chinese people
came at a point of their peak holiday
season many are affected many have lost
loved ones or are enduring the illness
of loved ones and I want the Chinese
people to know that they have the
deepest sympathies of the United States
of America let me also say an echo what
secretary azar said which is we are
deeply appreciative of the close
cooperation we have with the Chinese
government as we work together to try to
find appropriate ways to address any
risks and challenges from this virus and
finally the United States will continue
to cooperate with China in ways that we
could potentially provide assistance
including technical assistance and also
to the extent extent possible any
critical supplies that the Chinese need
in order to address this virus and we
are working very hard to find donors and
make arrangements so that we can begin
to undertake a robust effort to help the
Chinese people get their arms around
this outbreak thank you Thank You
secretary vigan let me
let me next invite the Acting Deputy
Secretary of the Department of Homeland
Security Ken Cuccinelli
to take the podium for some comments
thank you Thank You mr. secretary I am
Ken Cuccinelli and the acting deputy
secretary at the Department of Homeland
Security and even the department's
representative on the task force led by
secretary azar several elements of the
Department of Homeland Security are
engaged in implementing the medical
strategy you heard described here
including customs Border Protection
which stands at our land ports seaports
and airports and I'll come back to the
airports in a moment particularly the
office of Field Operations personnel who
you see when you come back into the
country from your travels they're the
first line of defense when you when you
land and come to the country
additionally engages TSA the security
and the engagement with the airlines our
chief medical officer in the department
is insi WMD and there we were providing
medical support at the airports so we're
using contract authority that we have to
backfill the CDC personnel so they can
be freed up for other missions at the
airports where medical screening is
being focused FEMA continues to prepare
and support HHS preparations themselves
and then the United States Coast Guard
of course commands the ports of the
United States and deals with incoming
shipping which is obviously slower than
the airplanes but coming nonetheless and
we were prepared to deal with each of
those the president's Proclamation will
have customs border protection ensuring
that United States citizens legal
permanent residents and their immediate
families continue to enter the United
States though they those coming from
huai province as you heard from the
secretary will be subject to quarantine
and the others from China to screening
we will be implementing a funneling
effort at the airports this is done
under the authority of the customs
Border Protection and it will include
seven airports so starting five o'clock
on Sunday
Eastern Time incoming flights from China
will be funneled through seven airports
those airports are JFK Chicago's O'Hare
in San Francisco Seattle Atlanta
Honolulu and LAX this is done under
CBP's authority will be executed by the
Secretary of the Department of Homeland
Security consistent with the president's
Proclamation and in support of that
effort again so we can focus the
expertise of the of the medical
professionals that will do the screening
to implement this we'll continue to
support the medical efforts across the
country both at our ports our land sea
and air as well as with personnel
standing up some of the resiliency
measures that HHS has been working on
for some time thank you
Thank You secretary Cuccinelli at this
point we'd be happy to take some of your
questions governor would you started
Thank You mr. secretary
if the risk is really low could you talk
about why go to such an extreme as a
public health emergency why are we
taking such such measures so these are
actually fairly incremental measured
steps on top of the steps we've already
progressively been taking you'll notice
that many airlines have already stopped
direct flights from China have pulled
that down we're seeing a significant in
the nation could comment on the numbers
we're seeing or homeland security we've
seen a significant reduction in people
from the u.s. going to China people from
China coming to the u.s. already this
just helps us focus our efforts so that
we as we're dealing with the unknowns
that dr. Fauci spoke about earlier
unknowns around incubation period
unknowns about beasts the speed of
transmissibility unknowns about
asymptomatic transmission unknowns about
severity that we take appropriate
measured Prudential steps so we can
focus our resources because it's the
bread and butter I've talked to you
before about the bread and butter of
public health is identify people who
might be symptomatic or might have the
disease diagnosed isolate treat contact
trace that's a significant undertaking
as we have already done with these six
individuals in the United States who've
been positively identified we have to
focus those resources the mandatory
quarantine for people coming in from
Hebei province will that be home
quarantine or will that be in an
institutional setting that would be at
an appropriate quarantine facility of
some kind for those individuals for the
US citizens returning to the United
States from having been in China within
the previous 14 days they would be
funneled as Secretary Cuccinelli spoke
of they would be screened appropriately
to see if they had present any type of
symptoms of the disease and then they
would be asked to self isolate at home
over the 14 days but for individuals
from who Bay because that is the
epicenter of this with such high
immediate transmission we filled these
additional measures of quarantine for up
to 14 days are appropriate Hallie could
I just follow it have you selected
specific quarantine centers we have
selected them we will announce those as
DHS implements with the airlines that
funneling activity was self quarantine
look like for the people who are self
quarantine 8 but how do you enforce that
with the mechanisms surrounding that
because it also speak to you just
describe this as sort of incremental
stuff I believe this is obviously
significant the quarantine of citizens
in this country what is your message to
Americans who are watching us on the
news who are seeing this who are feeling
really alarmed by the steps of this
administration is taking about the
spread of corona virus in general here
you say the risk is low but then they
see this action being taken and I think
some people might be freaked out by that
I hope not I hope that people will see
that their government is taking
responsible steps to protect them these
are these are preventive steps the risk
is low in the United States the risk is
low of transmissibility the risk of
contracting the disease is low but our
job is to keep that risk low as much as
we can by taking appropriate
preventative steps so that's that's
that's the approach we're taking let me
ask dr. Redfield if he can talk a bit
about we this is we do this type of
quarantine and self isolation work
basically every day working very closely
I want to stir
something that we've not mentioned
enough working very closely with our
state and local public health partners
there just as we do with emergency
response we serve as a backup and
expertise and a border type force but
the state and local authorities are the
backbone of our public health
infrastructure and we work with them
daily to help with our quarantine
stations and activities but dr. Bradley
can you talk a bit about self isolation
Thank You mr. secretary
clearly we've stratified the risk groups
here is was already alluded to from
Hubei province where there really is
aggressive transmission those
individuals are going to come and be
required to have 14 days of up to 14
days of institutional transmission then
there's a large category of individuals
coming back to China as we stand here
today over half of the reported cases in
China China now or not in Hubei but when
you look at their history it's that you
got they got infected
probably over eighty eighty-five percent
of them got infected from who pay those
individuals will then be actively
screened when they come into one of the
seven airports for significant risk as
well as any evidence of any symptoms in
the absence of any reason to advance
them into a clinical evaluation at that
port of entry they will be allowed to
complete their travel back to their home
where they then will be monitored by the
local health departments in a self
monitoring situation in their home we
did this in in in the West Africa Ebola
outbreak we did it but I want to
emphasize at that time over 98% of the
American public voluntarily accepted the
importance of this and we think and we
continue to believe the American public
will see this as something to their
benefit to their family's benefit
obviously their communities benefit so
that's the current situation one of the
aspect of this that I think is important
very recently there was a case of
a woman who was in China and came to
Germany and had a interaction
professional interaction with a
professional partner she had no symptoms
at the time she went back to China and
got sick this individual with whom she
had an interaction contracted the corona
virus at a time that she had no symptoms
he then transmitted it to two of his
colleagues so then our four cases one of
the problems with when the virus is
transmitted in an asymptomatic way and
as this implications it puts a terrible
burden on the screening process how do
you screen somebody you know remember
back with the ol Ebola doesn't get
transmitted unless you're actively very
ill and you know that it's very very
clear when you can transmit a virus at a
time when you're asymptomatic that just
puts that extra burden on screening and
as a lot of people come in it's going to
be very difficult given that Germany
data that you just cited are the 195
people being quarantined right now are
they getting tested every day dr.
Redfield described clear clearly they're
all isolated and and will be for the 14
days we have done virus isolation but I
want to be clear the current tests that
we developed at CDC is not we're not
sure of natural history of how the virus
is isolated can you isolate it one day
then three days later you can and we are
seeing in the cases that are in the
hospital we've seen people had
detectable virus and they didn't have
detectable virus and then three days
later they had detectable virus we're
using the virus cultures right now in
these individuals more to help us learn
about this virus how much a symptomatic
carriage in fact is there so I want
people to understand that distinction
we're not using it as a release criteria
because we don't know the natural
history of how this virus is secreted
and this is what we're continuing to
learn
that the thousands of people that pass
through the US screenings so far are not
care that they don't have coronavirus so
this is why it's such a layered approach
we are going to see additional cases in
this country we've already seen in the
six cases we defined a number of them
came in asymptomatic so this is why we
had that multi-layered approach and have
really worked hard to engage the medical
community in the United States of the
six cases that we diagnosed so far one
was picked up by hospital airport
screening four were picked up by astute
doctors and the most recent was picked
up by CDC doing aggressive contact
raising orders can you you reference the
Airlines earlier can you or your
colleague from the Department of
Transportation give us an update on the
administration's thinking about a travel
ban on Airlines in general being
prohibited for flying to and from China
there is no travel ban joel's about the
assistant secretary Department
transportation I think many of you are
who've been following this are aware I'm
all of the other three US carriers have
been flying between the US and China
have announced that they are taking down
all of their passenger flights and they
announced that before any action by the
administration so we are working closely
with our counterparts in the our Chinese
aviation counterparts and we'll be
working going forward with both the US
and the Chinese passenger airlines about
their flight plans going forward
considering more drastic action beyond
the voluntary measures that the airline
taking so far in his doctor - I'm sorry
secretaries are mentioned earlier this
is an evolving situation but at the
moment no about what we're seeing on on
air traffic numbers so yeah I'll start
it off and then turn it over to acting
deputy secretary Cucinelli so in terms
of passengers traveling between the
United States and China as you might
expect over the course of the last
couple of weeks the passengers loading
in the u.s. to fly to China have dropped
to almost none passengers a continue to
have a high what we call load factor a
high rate of passengers coming from
China to United States however so the US
carriers though as they're pulling out
they represent just under forty percent
of the passenger capability so with that
we have been seen already in the course
of the last week to ten days a
significant decrease the number of
passengers that have been going between
the United States and China and the
Department of Homeland Security does an
excellent job of tracking those numbers
day to day so just to speak to the
numbers since the Chinese have locked
down Wuhan and the Huai province which
was eight days ago memory serves travel
from China to the United States as of
yesterday had dropped by close to 20
percent travel from the United States to
China had dropped by well more than 50
percent and this is with the sort of
market response that Joel referenced by
the airlines and the voluntary actions
taken by travelers I would note for you
all that it's not a lot of data but over
the last five days the number of
American citizens traveling from China
back to the United States has been
rising so even while the total number is
going down it does look to us initially
like Americans at least some of them are
returning back home
we're everything how confident are you
in the accuracy of these tests if
somebody is testing negative and then
they later test positive can you have
confidence in here testing negative or
something that you don't have it so I
mean I think the question you ask is
really one of the fundamental basis of
why this decision was made if we had an
absolutely accurate test that was very
sensitive and very specific then we
could just test people and say okay
we're good to go I want to get back to
the broad concept that I mentioned when
I made my brief introduction about the
unknowns we don't know the accuracy of
this test we haven't done enough people
who came in were negative then all of a
sudden they were positive you can have
virus in your nasal secretions or you
couldn't and still be infected I mean it
isn't like it's a horrible test but it
is not a test that's absolute I spoke to
a reporter the other day talking about
tests so when you're talking about HIV
if a person is HIV and I draw their
blood I can tell you 100% whether they
have HIV or not 100% that's not even
near where we are with this topic a
gradual approach of the secretary in
terms of what you're doing right now
what measures do you have sort of in the
tool kit if this gets worse well like to
ask perhaps dr. Catholic to talk a bit
about our approach obviously at this
point as I've said the risk here in the
United States is quite low for any
individual the risk is low our job is to
work to keep that that way but we have
public health tools that we use we
exercise constantly in the event of
larger scale infectious disease
outbreaks and that's what we would
that's what we would rely on should we
end up seeing more cases in the United
States but it's exactly these measures
that help make any additional cases more
manageable to use the tools dr. Catlett
will talk about well thank very much mr.
secretary and my role in this is really
precautionary at this stage and
everything that's been done at this
point has been incremental proportionate
and precautionary and so my
responsibilities are work across the
federal government as well as within HHS
to ensure that we're posture should this
virus kind
continue to expand and so domestically
we're working on working with our
private sector healthcare preparedness
we're working specifically around supply
chain resilience because much of our
healthcare products come from overseas
and we're also working actively with NIH
and our DoD colleagues as well as our
top darpa colleagues and the private
industry to develop better Diagnostics
possible therapeutics as well as
vaccines which dr. Foxx Pfau she can
speak more about so we're really taking
a very I would say cautious but
deliberate and methodical approach to
ensure that come with May we're prepared
Thank You international travel what's
the message to people who need to travel
to the region and what benchmark will
you have for when this gets with it
so let me ask dr. Redfield if you could
talk a bit about just giving your
assessment as a health professional
about the international travel generally
and then the types of factors maybe for
dr. pouchy that we'll be looking at as
we again attempt hopefully temper
temporary measures titrated try to just
keep a pause on the situation Thank You
mr. secretary
I think as dr. Fauci said right now
there's a lot of unknowns obviously
almost every other day we're learning
something we didn't know the day before
about this we'll continue to do that
probably the most important thing from
our perspective is whether or not
there's expansion of what I call
sustained community human to human
transmission right now that is limited
in large part to the who Bay Area and
the broader China we've had some
isolated human to human transmission in
some of the cases that have gone
internationally I mentioned we've had 12
so far that have been defined in the
whole world so that's going to be
important to see if there's broadening
of sustained human to human transmission
I think that's going to really be the
major the major thing that we're going
to be looking at as the secretary said
these precautionary message messages and
actions that have been put out today it
really is intended to keep this virus
from causing significant consequences to
the American public thank you all very
much and again I just want to stress
first the most important thing that we
can be doing is what we are doing which
is offering to help the Chinese
government and assist them in helping
them to control the spread of the novel
coronavirus in China working with them
as closely as possible as well as with
the World Health Organization second the
risk to Americans is low you have a team
here you have an experienced first class
the world's best public health care
system infrastructure and professionals
looking out for you making judgments
like this scaling them up as appropriate
to work to keep this from becoming an
issue that would be of concern for you
to keep that risk low so thank you all
very much
[Music]
this argument about absolute immunity
which yes presidents have always dreamed
about and asserted but which has never
succeeded in any court in the land
it was ridiculed in the case of Harriet
Miers it was made short shrift in the
case of Don Magan where the judge said
no we don't have Kings here in the 250
years of jurisprudence there is not a
single case to support the proposition
that the president can